Dodgers bowed out in a dramatic fashion
last night Jorge Castillo was there the
Dodgers beat writer for the LA Times
kind enough to work late night get up
early for us thank you or hey how
confident were you that the Dodgers
wouldn't close this out when Dave
Roberts went to Clayton Kershaw I'd say
pretty confident but obviously everyone
knows Clayton Kershaw's history and it's
not a pretty one in the postseason so
when he gets that at me in there on
three pitches you're thinking okay the
Dodgers just might be the Dodgers night
and then he comes back out there to face
an MVP candidate Anthony Rendon and two
pitches later it's a one-run game and a
pitch later it's a tie game so it
happened also it happened so quickly
that uh it was pretty stunning just saw
just how it happened just how quickly it
happened and then obviously the you went
to the tenth inning and Joe Kelly um
gives up the the grand slam just the way
it happened last night I was stunning
just a team that 106 games to lose that
way it was just a shock to pretty much
everyone there we knew that the bullpen
was vulnerable and I know that we're a
results-based sports society here Jorge
but you know the Nationals had to dance
around their bullpen as well and and and
you know try to close out games here but
you know wired the Dodgers not playing
anymore
it's funny because the entire series the
strategy everyone talks about when the
Dodgers win this series by Nick milking
waiting out the dogs national starters
and getting to the bullpen and last
night the opposite active mom it was
last night what happened was to seem
like Dave Roberts didn't trust some guys
down there him if he made a couple of
wrong decisions I know as you said where
it's all over you know hindsight's 20/20
we can you know blame the manager and
I'm not one assertable one said all that
but you know some of the decisions last
night a couple of them you know in the
moment you're kind of just wondering but
what's is thinking here what's the sort
of thought process going on is you know
keep implications Clayton Kershaw in
there to face to Rend own and Soto and
you know Kershaw's a great history
obviously one of the greatest pictures
of maybe the greatest picture of a
generation a future hall-of-famer but
he's had trouble giving up home runs a
season he's not the same pitcher he's
proven at the entire year.then you're
facing an Sudheer and don't want
by far the two best hitters in that
lineup you know that's sort of a tough
stretch there and then going with Joe
Kelly you know first second inning there
he had not gone more than one inning
since August
he's been erratic all season long you
know yattawan Soto you can you
intentionally walk Juan Soto with first
base open with Adam choleric we're
guiding about three times in the series
waiting in the bullpen it's just all
kind of you know head scratching yeah
that moved there that last one you
talked about that was the one that I
thought we were going to see were they
really chanting fire Dave Roberts at
Chavez Ravine last night I can hear fire
Dave Roberts I heard a lot of boos when
he came out to get sick the boss and Joe
Kelly and then when he walked back after
he gave the ball to Kelly against and I
didn't hear fire Dave Roberts but
probably because I was sort of you know
honed in on figuring out what I was
going to write but I heard a lot of
booze and it's a lot as I've ever heard
booze as for Dave Roberts you know don't
Pulaski was sitting next to me and he
was saying he never heard Dave Roberts
booed that loudly at Dodger Stadium and
it's yeah the people were upset they
weren't happy with decision making the
Dave Roberts made last night is he safe
how safe is he mine so my initial
reaction to that would be I think he
said he just signed a three-year so his
contract has picked up and Austin was
picked up last year and then it's three
years remaining after this they signed
an extension through 2022 so my initial
my gut instinct is yes he stays it was
lovely last night but they still want to
under six games you know the franchise
record I just it's tough to see a
manager get fired after that well that's
why I don't know were they bad moves or
bad performances or can we separate the
two I think both I said you know it's
hard I know it's a cop-out answer but
you know in the moment I think people
were just wondering wait is this the
right move here I think the Clayton
Kershaw move I think I said that's more
defensible you know you're going with
the guy that Sutton was available you
know he's he had that you know he's one
of the greatest pitches of his
generation you trust him in that spot he
had just gotten had a meeting out with
three pitches two three one game
even Joe Kelly in there I think is the
one that that that's really kind of
head-scratching and yeah in both cases
you know Joe Kelly didn't make the
pitches you needed to make playing her
shot didn't make the pitches you needed
to make but there was both there was
history on both sides very recent
history that suggested that they weren't
the right people for that situation yeah
and and I also said this this morning
and I thought this in the moment if
you're gonna complain I know what we
know what the end result is but let's
say you didn't bring in Kershaw and
let's say you went to your other
pitchers in the bullpen and you lost
then we would be critical Dave Roberts
by saying you had Clayton Kershaw there
I mean the Nationals use Scherzer why
wouldn't you use Clayton Kershaw so I
think because we know how to ended
therefore it's easier to criticize but I
think we would have been critical of
Dave if he didn't bring in Clayton
Kershaw and they lost I think that's
fair I think that's fair and you know
it's a tough job obviously you know
we're here to criticize every move every
result and you know it's favoring Dave
Roberts it's pretty curse off it's not
about any given up one run and the
Dodgers somehow in that game it's you
know we're not talking about this
obviously but it's part of the job it's
part of the gig especially in this
market a market that hasn't seen a World
Series championship since 1988 there the
first thing for one it's you know the
last two World Series losing in the
World Series
I just feeling around here that it was
just all right cool let us know when
you're in the World Series and when you
win it you know we've seen you guys do
this in the regular season we've seen
guys go to the World Series before we're
not satisfied what do you think is worse
losing like this or losing in the World
Series I think just given the reaction
from the criminai last night's and the
players I say losing this way guys were
when Clayton Kershaw's eyes were red and
puffy red shell choked up Walker Buehler
was wiping away tears it was not that
sort of reaction in the last couple of
years you know is a very emotional sort
of raw clubhouse in there I think
they're just stunned I'll get in so
quickly I'll leave you with this whose
career would you want as of right now
Mike Trout or Clayton Kershaw
who I go with my trap I think my child
he's obviously the best playing baseball
he has been for maybe seven years at
this point yeah but he has named
postseason he's got with three three
at-bats or some third you know three
games I'm younger though yes Mike here's
a chance to turn us around
well here's more of a chance and you
know theoretically he'll be playing a
lot longer he's a position player who
you know unless injuries sort of rock up
here he'll have a lot of chances more
chances to do this and get to the World
Series with one one where's Clayton
Kershaw you know based on the last you
know sort of the trajectory the last
couple years yes he was very expected
this year I think he's got a 303 RA but
he's running on a chance to see the
picture I'm you know these guys don't
last very long compared to the distance
Blair and Mike trout's been the best one
in baseball for about seven years now
yeah but cursedolls not down old yes I
know that's the thing but that's 88 88
to 90 miles an hour now he's not the
same pitcher he was he just did it
yeah and then you want a big contract
too you know so is he now a third or
fourth starter or maybe is he gonna drop
that far he was number three starter you
know on general had a you know started
to Austin our game he's an anything else
I Young Award candidate and then walk
would be the start in Game one in game
five which is pretty much all you need
to know what the Dodgers think about him
so I think I'm sorry say Clayton Kershaw
was number three starters with the
Dodgers this year
Jorge thanks for getting up we know it
was a late night we appreciate your time
no problem thank you that's where hey
Casteel he covers the Dodgers for the LA
time for more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on be our live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]